[Música]
con una lectura que es con mi decisión
para hacer ciencia rosario castellanos
donde pregunta 14 con las a la ciudad
que le da la destreza de su oficio por
qué y para qué describe pero señor es
obvio porque alguien cuando yo era
pequeña dijo que la gente como yo no
existe
porque su cuerpo no proyecta sombra
porque no es roja peso en la balanza
porque su nombre es de los que se
olvidan pero no no es tan sencillo
escribe porque yo un día adolescente mis
líneas de un espejo y no había nadie se
da cuenta del vacío y junto a mí los
otros chorreaban importancia y luego ya
adulta ya madura descubrí que la palabra
tiene una virtud si es exacta es letal
y en monclova coahuila una ciudad al
norte del país soy la primera de una
familia de cuatro hijos y la única mujer
cuando tenía ocho años padres
acertadamente me regalaron un juego de
química
además de una mancha que sigue vigente
en la pared de la casa
descubrí una de mis más grandes pasiones
que es la ciencia cualquier dicho que me
encontraba en el jardín era
minuciosamente inspeccionado para saber
cómo funcionaba
me maravillaba la vida como tal desde
ahí empecé a hacer destiladoras
posteriormente decidí escribir ser
químico farmacobiólogo en la universidad
autónoma de san luis potosí tos de
profesores y profesoras maravillosas que
se encargaron de introducirme en el
conocimiento de la química la física y
la biología además de explotar mis
habilidades técnicas y científicas un
día tuve la fortuna de ser elegida para
participar en un verano de la
investigación científica ahí tuve la
oportunidad de trabajar con el efecto de
los plaguicidas que son ampliamente
utilizados
en el campo agrícola mexicano y ver cómo
hace el trabajo del sistema nervioso
central específicamente el aprendizaje y
la memoria eso definió mi área de
investigación
decidí hacer un maestro y doctorado de
neurociencias en la unam y
posteriormente estuve trabajando bueno
fui contratada en la universidad
autónoma de madrid por el ministro de
educación y ciencia español trabajando
en la generación caracterización y
aislamiento sobre todo de células negra
los troncales humanas es un tema
tema de punta en ciencia pero que
desgraciadamente méxico era prohibido
bueno estaba un poco difícil trabajarlo
ahí tuve mujeres de maravilloso que fue
un día maravilloso como científico y un
grupo de mujeres en su laboratorio
estudiantes y científicas que ayudaron a
terminar la información
qué tan fácil es cada una
ser científica es difícil al igual que
como en cualquier otra profesión
a las mujeres científicas representamos
el 30% de la población la unesco
considera que somos una minoría en
méxico nos quedamos tan atrás
si vemos méxico está por delante
seriamente apenas el 29 abajo de bolivia
además el porcentaje o la proporción de
mujeres en ciencias se ha ido
incrementando a lo largo del tiempo si
lo vemos desde 1984 que teníamos un 18.1
por ciento hasta un 36.2 por ciento en
el 2016 ahora qué hacen estas mujeres
una vez tienen una maestría un doctorado
y empiezan a estar en el campo laboral
generalmente son se integran a
universidades estatales oa la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
o algún centro de investigación un
ejemplo lo podemos ver en la siguiente
diapositiva en la que vemos
la distribución de la planta académica
por categoría en la nuestra local
universidad autónoma sabéis potosí
en la categoría de profesor tiempo
completo en esta institución nos permite
realizar la investigación de una manera
más sencilla entre comillas y las
mujeres que tenemos esta categoría de la
universidad corresponde hasta mil autos
hasta 2017 al 31 por ciento
también restan las categorías es más o
menos igual a excepción de los técnicos
académicos que existen tienen
aproximadamente un 53
con datos por tanto son de profesores
ahora como todos los científicos los
autos las profesionistas los científicos
somos evaluados y estamos constantemente
evaluados por un organismo que es el
sistema nacional de investigadores que
hace los niveles me reconoce el sni el
sistema lesionado de investigadores
reconoce cinco categorías el profesor
andrew cada candidato al sistema
nacional instigador en el nivel 1 el
nivel 2 el nivel 3 y el investigador
emérito
cómo se asignan los niveles de acuerdo a
la productividad a mayor productividad
evidentemente es mayor el nivel vamos a
ver cómo se distribuyen las poblaciones
en las categorías y vemos que conforme
aumenta el nivel de la esm y disminuye
la proporción de mujeres presentes en
cada uno de ellos prácticamente un
estudia positiva no está el investigador
emérito pero en los indicadores de
méritos que representan solamente el 16
por ciento
a casa cuando estamos hablando de la
participación de las mujeres en espacios
acción
y
llamamos a esta decisión a las juntas de
gobierno a las autoridades oa los
consejos universitarios aquí podemos ver
que el así el 70% de los que están
encargados de tomar decisiones en las
instituciones son hombres
en nuestra propia universidad no hemos
tenido una sola rectora en la historia
de la facultad de medicina solamente ha
habido una sola que está pasando
pues bueno una de las cosas importantes
que quiero resaltar es que las mujeres
además de sus 40 horas de trabajo diario
bueno más bien semanal
tener que emplear o emplear 30 horas más
en el cuidado de hijos o de familiares
sin tomar en cuenta las horas que ellas
emplean en labores domésticas es decir
no tenemos mucha diferencia 1900
perdón 1905 cuando marie curie escribía
a su hermano que decía tengo mucho
trabajo con la casa de las niñas
designadas en el laboratorio no sé cómo
voy a poder arreglar me vas con todo
entonces qué es lo que está pasando
sucede qué pasa en el sistema que no
apoya a las mujeres para el desarrollo
de una carrera científica y académica
este es un punto de reflexión y les
aseguro que muchas de las instituciones
ha intentado buscar mediar la pero no lo
ha logrado no dejamos que un punto de
reflexión que voy a retomar al final
hace 10 años yo tuve la oportunidad de
volver a méxico
y me incorporé como profesor
investigador en la facultad de medicina
esta contratación de permitió mí allí en
con la investigación en neurociencia y
además acerca de mi familia hacer
ciencia no es fácil porque implica
técnicas implica hacer un experimento de
una vez si no sale es volver a empezar
todo el circuito si sale este padrísimo
porque tenemos tres datos para analizar
y muchas veces terminamos con más
preguntas de las que iniciamos por eso
lo divertido lo que no es divertido es
trabajar en una universidad estatal en
la cual tiene recursos precarios para
investigación lo que no es divertido es
tratar de mediar el tiempo que quieres
crear la investigación que tienes una
sobrecarga de docencia gestión y
burocracia lo que no es divertido es el
día a día a veces lidiar los
micromachismos y violencias que a veces
viene hasta de las propias mujeres
lo que no es divertido es luchar el
tiempo así cuando en 5000 convocatorias
para buscar
los financiamientos para poder hacer la
investigación
muchas veces evidentemente todos sabemos
que en méxico tenemos cada vez menos
presupuesto para investigación entonces
que hace que defina nosotros los
científicos terminamos poniendo veces de
nuestra propia bolsa para poder hacerlo
no
muy bien
a pesar de su puesto negativo que les
acabo de contar lo que tenemos que hacer
o lo que hacemos nosotros es seguir
aunque no se vea la luz en el camino
seguir trabajando
una de las estrategias que a mí me ha
funcionado y ha sido por ensayo y error
es tener una red de colaboración
funcional afortunadamente se ha podido
llevar a cabo muchas de las
investigaciones que yo organizo en el
laboratorio otras las cosas importantes
de este trabajo en ciencia es que me han
permitido participar en la formación de
maestros y doctores actualmente se
encuentran trabajando en instituciones
nacionales e internacionales
entonces ahora tomo la pregunta qué es
lo que tenemos que hacer para mejorar y
apoyar la carrera de las mujeres en
ciencia
bueno
tiene un mundo tenemos tanta violencia
donde muchos proponen que la violencia
es la solución
en una sociedad donde estamos
acostumbrados a la recompensa inmediata
yo considero que la solución es la
educación no es la solución inmediata
pero sí es la solución
así que si recordamos las mujeres desde
épocas ancestrales
hemos sido creadoras sanadoras maestras
así que apelamos a la divinidad femenina
y masculina para poder educar ahora a
nuestros nuevos niños y niñas en la
tolerancia el respeto el amor
la empatía
porque al final estos niños a los cuales
nosotros vayamos a tumbar les los tabús
y las creencias que hemos arrastrado a
lo largo de años van a ser las únicas la
única esperanza para tener una sociedad
en la cual tengamos una un trato de
igualdad igualitario entre hombres y
mujeres
es así
la mayor aporte por lo menos yo
considero de la sociedad científica es
justo eso la educación muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]